I think the public is as the general
public it depends on the country I would
say but has lost the faith in science
that we once had after World War Two and
Sputnik of course that created a stage
for science and people look to science
to solve many problems and now they've
become maybe a little jaded as we would
say a little too accustomed to what
progress we've made and they no longer
have maybe the confidence in science I
think that we had at that time for sure
yeah yeah I mean I mean Sputnik was the
one that sort of that was that that was
what changed change to the life in the
u.s. and in terms of science and at
least in my generation I was in high
school when Sputnik went up and I
remember precisely that and it really
paved the way for me to go into science
and go through science so that was
important but that's getting harder and
harder I think yeah it says dick Sanders
there's a lot of faith being lost
there's now at least in the US and
attitudes that are very non-scientific
that are becoming prevalent that are
being supported at levels which which
which make it difficult for for science
in many ways whose the blame for that if
you blame anything system
I don't know I don't know you know
that's why I don't know it's it's really
it's really been frightening the last
few years to watch watch the watch the
change happen and can you see with your
students people who come to these our
students I mean we're we're both at
Institutes of Technology which has
probably the two highest and standards
for admission
in the US and so our students come in
emphasis you know interested in science
wanting to do science and so for our
students that we work with every day
it's not an issue it's it's outside of
that group would you see it how you see
it through the funding agencies and the
money they get which has well
fortunately this year I think increased
but there have been some difficult years
and although the government statements I
mean our government in any government
has positions and sometimes they are not
shall we say scientifically what we
would like them to be and that's that's
that's something that is very visible
and it's very distressing to see things
said that are just not true or certainly
debatable at best
you